welcome to another lecture of embryology
in this video we'll talk about the week
3 of embryonic development
and the events that happens during the
week three during the week 3 of
embryonic development major events
happen
so at the end of week two the blastocyst
had embedded into the endometrium
completely
so in in this at around day 14 to 15 we
can see the chorionic cavity has formed
and the by a bilaminar embryonic disc is
hanging in the chorionic cavity with the
help of primitive stock
which would be the future umbilical cord
now the major event that happens during
day 16 or the third week of embryonic
development is gastrulation
and this process is basically
helping the embryo to form multiple germ
layers namely the ectoderm mesoderm and
endoderm from the AP blast layer
now gastrulation is a process by which
different parts of the different cells
of the embryo moves into new location
and forms a different type of cells so
there are different morphogenetic
movement that happens like invagination
where cells move inward invaginates a
sheet of cells in vaginate inside
involution where one layer of cells uh
grows inside another defined layer there
is ingression delamination and epiboly
if you want to learn more about these
morphogenetic movement you can click on
the different video in the I button
right now we are not going to talk about
these in details but let me tell you
the key features of grass relation
gastrulation is all about coordinated
movement of cells and these movements
involve the entire embryo and the
patterns of gastrulation is very
different among Animal Kingdom but
gastrulation would be a set of movement
which are a combination of these basic
morphogenetic movements there could be a
combination of let's say in invagination
ingression and AP bully together just to
give you one example but all the
possible movements are not happening
together
a combination is taking place for a
given organism
now here is the human embryo here we can
see the epiblast and we can see the
hypoblast here
the cavity inside the epiblast is
amniotic cavity and here we can see the
yolk sac
now let us focus on this particular
region the bilaminar embryonic disk we
have to understand this to understand
the third week of development which is
comprising of I mean the biliminar
embryonic disc is comprising of AP blast
and the hypoblast layer gastrulation
involves highly choreographed movement
of these AP blast cells over time
eventually these AP blast cells would
give rise to three different lineages of
cell ectoderm mesoderm and endoderm so
in in a 3D situation imagine
chorionic
cast you can see the amniotic cavity in
yolk Sac just to orient you in this
situation and the bilaminar embryonic
disc is shown here so the first event
that happens in the embryonic
development is a thickening
throughout the midline of the embryoth
along the mid sagittal plane and this is
known as the Primitive streak
and this primitive streak grow grows
over the course of the next day and
these Primitives at the end of this
primitive streak in the cranial end
there is a Groove which forms this is
known as the Primitive Groove
so at this point of time the major body
axis is defined you can see the cranial
and the caudal end is well defined at
the end of this stage
formation of the Primitive streak also
indicates the beginning of the
gastrulation process
so formation of the Primitive streak is
very important because it defines a
major body axis here we can see at the
cranial end there would be a primitive
node
so the Primitive node has a depression
in it which is known as the Primitive
pit
cells move through the Primitive streak
inside and away from that which is known
as a particular morphogenetic movement
known as ingression
so during the gas relation what happens
is cells move towards the
primitive streak move down through the
Primitive streak and move inside the
Primitive streak now at this particular
illustration it might not be very visual
so let us explain that in bit more
details in a cross section you can see
the cellular movement through the help
of the arrows you can see the cells are
moving through the Primitive streak
going down and moving away from the
Primitive streak this is even better
visualized in this kind of graphic cells
are moving towards primitive streak
moving down through the Primitive streak
and moving away
and when they are moving away they would
eventually get a new fate and this kind
of set of coordinated movement is known
as ingression so the d-glam they
delaminate from one side and they
eventually move to a new destination and
become something else
so here we can see uh one important
structure in the cranial end which is
known as Pro or precodile plate this
particular structure would eventually
give rise to the oropharyngeal membrane
which ruptures to form the mouth and it
makes sense right in the cranial end we
would see the mouth opening so it
defines the cranial end as well
anyway this pre-codile or Pro Cardinal
plate also provide inductive signal for
the CNS formation or the neural tube
closure
so what forms the Primitive streak the
induction of primitive streak happens
with the help of several signaling
molecules like TGF beta wind bracury and
the opposing gradient of Cerberus and
lifting
so this defines the Primitive group and
primitive streak formation and
ultimately induce the ingression
movement of the AP blast cells so what
really happens after the cells of AP
blast ingresses inside the cells of AP
blast eventually replaces the cells of
the hypoblast and ultimately this would
form the definitive endoderm and this is
happening at the early stage of day 16.
eventually more cells would move in and
the intra-embryonic mesoderm would be
formed between the endoderm and the
so-called apiblast layer
after the intrambryonic mesoderm is
formed there are no more requirement of
increasing increasing cells so the cells
which are lagged behind and not any more
increasing they would form the
ectodermal region
so this is the last region to be formed
ectoderm so now at the end of day 16
ectoderm endoderm and mesoderm has been
formed now we entered the early stage of
Day 17. within the
tissue there is a formation of
notochordal process but just to orient
you this is the oropharyngeal membrane
cranial end and this is the cloical
membrane that means it's the caudalent
you can see the embryo is more thickened
or more bulky on the cranial side and
tapering and the coral side at this
point of time we can appreciate the
growth of the notochordal process
notochordal process would eventually
grow and form the notochord notochord
first of all give rise to the vertebrae
and eventually secretes molecules which
triggers the induction of neural plate
so neural neural induction is one of the
key event that happens at the end of the
third week
in this process notochord secretes
molecules like Sonic Hedgehog out of
many molecules which help the induction
of ectodermal region to form the new
rectoderm eventually that neurectodon
form of folds to form the neural tube so
imagine the entire ectoderm to be a thin
sheet
and during the process of new relation
this sheet is folding and forming a
tube-like organization if you look at
the Circle region you can clearly
understand the sheet is folding and
forming a tube and that's what happens
at the end of the third week of
gestation so as per summary we can say
gastrulation was the most important
event during the third week of gestation
and it involves coordinated movement
which results in formation of three gem
layers ectoderm mesoderm and endoderm
from the AP blast eventually these uh
germ layers would give rise to several
regions such as ectoderm would give rise
to CNAs brain skin Adrenal medulla for
example misogram would give rise to
kidney bone heart spleen Etc endoderm
would give rise to GI tract endocrine
system bladder urethra Etc anyway just
to recap what happens in the third week
first primitive streak defines the
beginning of the third week it also
marks the major body axis then one of
the major event that happens is the
gastrulation which forms three different
germ layers
at the end of day 16 and the transition
of day 17 notocordyl process starts to
form at the end of day 17 notochord is
formed and neural tube induction happens
in between day 19 to day 21 and that
ends the third week of embryonic
development so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up follow us on Facebook
and Instagram support us using super
tanks you can pay via PayPal paytm or
UPI see you in next video